in the tao of wu you're right
when my mother left the physical world i
lost one of my main links to the
universe
they say that you have an umbilical cord
and an etheric cord
which is the invisible cord that
attaches you to your soul your mother's
soul and all other souls
when one passes away you really lose
something
it's physical and mental it's real
part of you
dies
what have you learned about life from
your mother
i mean i learned life itself for my
mother
you know
being
one of 11 children
and seeing
the sacrifice that she gave to us
therefore given to life
uh it's really the greatest lesson of
life
the thing that uh
shook me as i wrote those words
was
coming up young
with arrogance
confidence
knowledge of
myself they called me the scientists
we was taught
you're the supreme being in order to be
the supreme being you've got to be
supreme amongst
other beings
um
i understand that more now than i did
then because then it was so literal
you know the word god
derived
basically from the greek language as
they say and it
meant wisdom strength and beauty
here we could have that
but the power to control life and death
is something that you would assume is a
god trait
so now here you are saying that you're a
god
right
and you're reading the bible how jesus
brought back lazarus
and you know now it's your turn to do
something
and when my mother was laying there in
the hospital bed
and air was no longer coming out of her
lungs and going into her lungs
where's my power to bring her back to
life
so you can't truly be god you're
powerless
yeah or god is not the definition that
we need to use to describe it
because it's a translation of wisdom
strength and beauty so you could be that
but uh so i'm asking your question what
did my mother teach me about life i
learned that day on physical passing
okay
you know i mean there's a physical me
you